bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne l'audition de martin hirsch part
à la mission d'information du sénat sur
le scandale du médiator
ancien directeur de cabinet de bernard
kouchner au secrétariat d'état à la
santé et ancien conseiller chargé de la
santé auprès de martine aubry entre 1997
et 1999
martin hirsch est aussi l'auteur d'un
ouvrage sur les conflits d'intérêts il a
été entendu hier par les sénateurs de la
mission d'information sur le scandale du
médiator
une audition qui intervient alors qu'un
sondage publié hier montre que 66% des
personnes interrogées s'estiment de
moins en moins confiante envers les
industries pharmaceutiques depuis l'
affaire du médiator tout de suite donc
l'audition de martin donc nous allons
poursuivre nos auditions avec monsieur
hirsch que je n'ai pas effectivement
besoin de présenter puisque il a exercé
de nombreuses responsabilités
donc nous l'auditionner non seulement en
raison des fonctions qu'il a occupées
dans les années 20 des années 90 mais
aussi pour les ses compétences et les
propositions qu'il a été amené à faire à
la suite de cette affaire du médiateur
cette affaire du médiateur qu'il a été
amené à faire excuser moi ici ou là je
parle pas seulement de son livre qu'ils
étaient
qui a été publiée avant faire du
médiator mais surtout des interviews
qu'il a pu donner ici et là et qui me
semble susceptible de nourrir la
réflexion que nous avons actuellement
dans la perspective du rapport que nous
prendrons public que à la fin du mois de
juin
donc vous avez été donc directeur du
cabinet du secrétaire d'état à la santé
monsieur bernard kouchner et ancien
conseiller chargé de la santé au cabinet
du ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité mal à martine aubry de 97 à
99 et donc avant de vous interroger je
voudrais et vous demande vous informer
que cette séance donc cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et fait l'objet d'un
enregistrement audiovisuel en vue de
cette diffusion sur public sénat et sur
le site internet du sénat et pour la
forme que vous demanderez folie un
intérêt au jeudi pour la forme parce que
je crois savoir que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup
sinon pas du tout c'est pourquoi je dis
pour la forme
enfin c'est vous qui allez répondre un
bien dru peut-être peut-être est-ce que
je me trompe
pardon oui les les liens d'intérêts si
vous avez des liens d'intérêt avec que
les entreprises produisant ou
exploitants des produits de santé ou des
organismes de conseil intervenant sur
ces produits
bon alors je veux tu être surpris par
votre réponse enfin jeu
vous écoute merci monsieur le président
réjouissent que vous me posez cette
question
non je n'ai ni dans le présent ni dans
le passé donc quelqu un lien naturel
je ne suis pas surpris ajaccio aucun
lien financier jamais de voyages
rémunéré par l'industrie pharmaceutique
jamais une rémunération venant d'accord
de l'industrie pharmaceutique jamais tu
deviens direct ou indirect avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais des
responsabilités exercées dans ce secteur
là c'est pour ça que je disais pour la
forme
n'avez vous rien compris alors vous avez
la possibilité si vous le souhaitez de
faire une intervention liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes et ensuite madame la
rapporteure vous interrogera ainsi que
mes collègues ici présents
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quelques mots
d'abord sur mes interactions mes
responsabilités dans le secteur
ça commence en 92 93
je suis le conseiller juridique du
ministère de la santé au moment de la
loi de sécurité sanitaire du 4 janvier
93 qui crée l agence du médicament et
j'étais dans ce bâtiment quand avec le
sénateur huriez nous avons mis en place
l'amendement sénatorial qui a introduit
lagence du médicament dans une réforme
qui auparavant n'étaient que la réforme
la transfusion sanguine est donc suivie
d'un peu près l'évolution de ces de ces
institutions
j'étais ensuite pendant deux ans
directeur de la pharmacie centrale des
hôpitaux de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris qui m'a permis de
connaître un peu y compris les
difficultés les pressions qui peut y
avoir dans le domaine du médicament
et puis j'étais ensuite donc directeur
de cabinet de bernard kouchner au moment
de la deuxième loi de sécurité sanitaire
celle qui transforme les agences du
médicaments en afssaps et
là ça je me suis retrouvé ensuite comme
directeur général de l'afssa entre 99 et
2005 a continué du coup à être dans les
comités de sécurité sanitaire dans les
réunions soit près des ministres auprès
des directeur général de la santé qui
réfléchissaient sur la sécurité
sanitaire
je commence également par vous dire
qu'effectivement je fais partie de ceux
qui n'ont pas entendu parler du médiator
avant avant très récemment
y compris c'est pendant cette période 97
99 ou pourtant nous avions très
régulièrement autour du secrétaire
d'état
l'ensemble des responsables des
autorités sanitaires s'agisse du
directeur général de la santé de
l'agencé du médicament et c'est pour
faire des points réguliers sur les
alertes éventuelles et notamment le
moment où le rapport de la cnam de
l'assurance maladie vient vers l' agence
du médicament
c'était un moment où nous étions tout le
temps ensemble pour le moment où on a on
essayait de mettre le frein sur le
vaccin contre l'hépatite b qui avait
pris et et donc les épidémiologistes
dont on parle lucien benhaim etc on se
voyait tout le temps sur ce sujet là et
je crois vraiment je ne vais pas avoir
été des trompes et qu' aucun d'entre eux
a dit il ya par ailleurs une question
qui est en train d'émerger sur sur le
sur le médiator moi mon nom en quelques
minutes mon point de vue là dessus c'est
que je pense qu'il faut pas trop se
focaliser sur les procédures
administratives l'organisation
administrative qui est certainement sur
lesquelles il peut y avoir des
modifications
je pense que l'une des raisons qui
peuvent
qu'il est difficile quand on lit relit
soit le rapport de gars soit tout ce qui
a été écrit de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé sans imaginer que le système était
sous emprise économique et que
et sous influence et que globalement il
est pas si mal
je reviendrai il est pas si mal qui est
responsable du médicament qui ne soit
pas un ministre qui est la
responsabilité de l'autorisation sur lui
la responsabilité sanitaires et de
l'autorisation et du retrait de la mise
sur le marché
je pense qu'il est pas si mal qui est un
organisme d'état il est dans les
questions de sécurité sanitaire avec des
responsabilités bien identifiés qui est
des gens qui que ça empêche de dormir
pour de savoir s'il ya ou non certains
médicaments sur le marché
je pense qu'on peut revoir les questions
d'architecturé des différentes
commissions mais que le problème à mon
sens est un peu plus en amont et il me
semble qu'il ya un lien entre le fait
qu'aujourd'hui après le médiator on
s'interroge sur un certain nombre de
médicaments sur le marché et le fait
qu'effectivement la france soit un pays
qui est grand consommateur de
médicaments pour lequel on voit
effectivement que l'influent ce qui peut
être exercée peut s'exercer du du bout
d'un bout à l'autre de la chaîne depuis
une influence qui peut être exercée sur
les patients avec un certain nombre
d'associations de patients qui sont
financées par l'industrie pharmaceutique
avec l'influent ce qui peut être exercée
sur la recherche publique avec la
recherche publique qui a été encouragé
ces dernières années a multiplié les
collaborations avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique et sans se dire qu'il
devait y avoir d'un côté une recherche
publique qui pouvait être effectivement
orienté vers l'innovation financé par
l'industrie pharmaceutique
à condition qu'ils restent une recherche
publics qu'ils soient strictement
indépendante 2
l'industrie pharmaceutique en remontant
avec l'influencé exercée sur les
médecins eux mêmes avec la visite
médicale les congrès médicaux les
voyages etc avec une influence exercée
sur les cercles d' expertise avec une
influence exercée sur le système
lui-même de de sécurité sanitaire j'ai
écrit je pense dit qu'il ait dit mme
bareigts strictement anormal et que
lorsque est détecté un problème ça ne
soit pas l'autorité sanitaire qui
commanditent finances pilotes
les études et que l'on se tourne vers le
laboratoire qui a un intérêt à maintenir
sur le marché les choses pour pouvoir
financer ses études et financé les
chercheurs qui du coup aussi éminent
soit il est intellectuellement brillant
soit-il ont été leurs chiffres
d'affaires soit de leurs laboratoires
publics soit de leur société de conseil
privé soit de leur rémunération
personnelle provient de du laboratoire
dont ils sont censés contrôler le
produit ce système si les leçons du
médiator n'est pas de mettre fin à tout
cela je pense que nous aurons beaucoup
d'autres médiator je continue sur le
système sous influence je pense que si
j'avais à récrire mon livre sur les
conflits d'intérêt
je réécris ray les chapitres que j'ai
bien nous interdit d'en écrire un autre
nom mais je je je je pense effectivement
que j'étais trop optimiste dans la
vision que j'avais en prenant comme
modèle
je pense quand même qu'on est passé de
qu'on a fait des progrès très importants
depuis l'époque des années 80 70 mais
que cependant tout ce qui a été mis à
jour
ces derniers mois montrent que
nous étions que au petit milieu du gué
sur ce qu'il fallait faire et que
notamment dans ce domaine là la question
de la transparence sur les intérêts
n'est pas suffisante puisque il faut
aller au delà et ados les allées jusqu'à
effectivement l'absence de il ya deux
choses qui m'ont frappé dans ce que on
voit aujourd'hui à la fois la part de
ceux qui parmi les experts avaient
encore des liens forts dans les experts
externes du système est à la fois le
fait que ce qui avait été conçu comme
équilibre avec l' expertise interne n'a
pas joué son rôle de garde-fou trois
secondes là dessus quand on créé l'
agence du médicament par l'amendement de
la loi du 4 janvier
93 on repose avec l'idée que
effectivement dans le système tel qu'il
est il faut à la fois pouvoir mobiliser
sur les expertises les meilleurs
chercheurs dont on n'arrivera pas à
faire en sorte qu'ils n'aient aucun lien
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais dont on se dit qu'au moins on
pourra rendre transparent et public
leurs liens et écarter certains d'entre
eux est con con contrebalancera les
liens que l'expertisé externe à part
construction dans le système français
aujourd'hui avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique par une expertise interne
de personnes dont le seul j'ai à dire
chef le seul financier doit être la
puissance publique et que l'un plus
l'autre fera qu'on a peut-être une
expertise interne qui seront pas des
gens qui auront le prix nobel où iront
les grands prix de recherche ou les
meilleures publications dans non dans
dans les journaux médicaux mais qui
seront strictement sans aucune influence
de l'industrie et des intérêts
économiques et qu'ils pourront du coup
contre balancer des experts qui seront
peut être plus pointu mais par ailleurs
un peu plus liés à l'industrie
pharmaceutique
on voit que du côté des experts ce n'est
pas un peu lié mais c'est souvent très
liés et que tu coules l'expertisé
interne n'a pas su pu été en mesure de
compte
balancer ce type ce type d' influence et
et je puis on voit au delà effectivement
que dans l'ensemble l'ensemble des
milieux politiques administratifs d'
expertise il ya une un des ddd
effectivement des liens d'intérêts qui
ne sont pas peut-être la responsabilité
directe de telle ou telle chose mais qui
crée un environnement dans lequel on ne
sait plus qui décident en fonction de
quoi qui conseille en fonction de quoi
c'est la raison pour laquelle il me
semble qu'il faut être radical
c'est à dire qu'il faut à la fois faire
en sorte que j'ai pas parlé que la forme
quoi
si je reprends depuis le départ
formation initiale et formation médicale
continue ne doit plus être dépendante de
l'industrie pharmaceutique du tout on en
est loin
deuxièmement que les congrès le fait que
les experts aya des congrès ne doit plus
dépendre de l'industrie pharmaceutique
même quand on lit l'excellent livre
d'irène frachon
elle raconte elle même comment quand
elle va dans un congrès pour parler de
lâcheté ap elle est là dans des congrès
qui sont peut-être pas financées par
servier mais qui sont financés par
d'autres quoi c'était quand j'ai lu son
livre de a jusqu'à z
j'étais absolument c'était estomaquant
de voir que cela reste comme ça c'est un
système qu'on connaît bien
si l'industrie pharmaceutique n'était
pas là il y aurait pas qu'au gré il ya
quelques temps on lisait la sptr qu'on a
auditionné nous disent mais heureusement
qu'ils sont là rendez vous contre rire
ici et s'il a dû alors je demande
comment les professions libérales qui ne
bénéficient pas de cette industrie
flamme and de l'estrie ferme city faut
pour se réunir en congrès peut-être
qu'il ya d'autres explications le succès
nateur sur lequel je déborde un peu du
mondial qu il peut arriver qu'il y ait
même genre de le même genre de dia mais
effectivement dans ce secteur là c'est
effectivement plaire mais on peut y
mettre fin
moi j'ai connu l'époque où dans les
maternités des hôpitaux de l'assistance
publique par exemple il y avait le tour
de l'est et les producteurs de lait
fournissait du lait gratuit
s'entendait avec les équipes
les obstétriciens pour dire pour faire
croire au pauvre maman qu'elle n'avait
pas le droit de changer de la une fois
qu'elle en avait essayé une marque pour
que s ii et chaque marque avait sa
semaine et en contrepartie on alimentait
la caisse pour financer les voyages
c'est le tour de l'est a été terminé le
tour de l'est a été exactement
voilà un bon système sous influence
malheureusement il existe encore
extrêmement largement et dans le secteur
libéral et dans le secteur public
on en a des témoignages tout le temps
doux formation initiale formation
continue congrès sociétés savantes bien
évidemment une société doit de sa vente
c'est pas une société achetée donc une
société doit être sa vente
elle ne doit pas être payés par
l'industrie pharmaceutique est pour le
moins dans l'urgence il faudrait
peut-être qu'elle signale aujourd'hui
quels sont les financements qu'elle
découle des privés y compris tous les
instituts qui ont des bourgs nom et qui
derrière on des financements privés
je crois vraiment qu'il peut être assez
assez assez radical je pense que la
visite médicale pour lequel il ya un
excellent rapport de l'igas aussi
malheureusement trop méconnu de 10 de
2007 qui montre bien comment fonctionne
la visite médicale est un élément
important
je remarque d'ailleurs que une fois que
j'ai dit cela
certains ont voulu porter plainte contre
moi en diffamation ou je ne sais quoi
et lorsqu'on s'est expliqué ils m'ont
dit que en fait ils partageaient un
certain nombre des constats y compris
s'ils considéraient qu effectivement la
visite médicale telle qu'elle
fonctionnait aujourd'hui il faut savoir
comment ça fonctionne c'est à dire que
les visiteurs médicaux et ondes par leur
chef
on leur explique attention il ya des
médecins qui sont des blaireaux
c'est le terme officieux mais
communément appelée on appelle un
blaireau un médecin qui prescrit pas
assez et qui refuse d'ouvrir grand la
porte à la visite médicale en disant
c'est pas la peine de perdre son temps
avec lui et il faut pas se tromper sur
les baisses d'effectifs de la visite
médicale les baisses d'effectifs de la
visite médicale ne veut pas dire qu'on
relâche la pression sur les
prescripteurs
ça veut dire qu'on cible mieux et plus
efficacement la pression sur sur des
prescripteurs bien identifiés comme
pouvant être un vecteur de boue stage
des médicaments et il serait intéressant
de savoir comment est-ce que ceux là ont
connaissance des informations qui
permettent de connaître parfaitement le
profil du prescripteur
moi je me souviens quand j'étais à la
pharmacie centrale des hôpitaux j'ai vu
une des entreprises venir me présenter
son logiciel sur lequel on pouvait d'un
médecin connaître combien il avait
prescrit qu'a été la clientèle autour
quel était le fonctionnement avec des
marques pharmacie d'à côté c'est elle et
google earth médical avant que google
existe avec une une un degré de
sophistication bien supérieur aux
données dont l'assurance maladie dispose
donc de l'ensemble de ces données
je pense sans parler effectivement
d'autres d'autres d'autres d'autres
liens d'intérêts et de qui l'industrie
pharmaceutique peut s'offrir les
services à tous niveaux de l'état je
pense par conséquent qu'il faut
effectivement au delà du de la question
de savoir si des taxes doivent financer
lagence de médicaments faire en sorte
qu'on puisse reconquérir de l'argent
public probablement financé par
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour financer
cette fois
pour par exemple
voilà par exemple pour qu'il ya de
l'argent qui deviennent de l'argent
public
la formation véhicules qu'ils puissent
financer l'ensemble de ces actions
c'est ce que lorsqu'on disait cela il ya
15 ans c'était sous la risée générale on
nous traitait d'idéalistes taha lors que
le sénat l'a dit il ya quelques temps on
a commencé à le prendre au sérieux
merci merci merci monsieur aucune des
agences ne la sait pas le moral écrit et
vous l'avez écrit aux laïcs les lecteurs
l'ont lu avec beaucoup d'intérêt c'est
en salle je rends mon passé armée au
sénat remercie ceux qui là et je pense
qu'il ne s'est pas trompé de diagnostic
de la rapporteure être est ce ainsi
puisque c'est elle qui rapportait sur ce
magnifique rapport vous avez terminé
monsieur préféré pas oui mais on va vous
relancez cieux bon eh bien madame alors
une petite question quand j'ai lu je
crois que c'était dans le jdd
vous avez donné beaucoup d'interviews
j'en ai glaner une parmi d'autres
c'est peut-être pas la plus importante
m'enfin j'ai été un peu si vous voulez
interpellé comme on dit par une phrase
que vous avez un labo adoptantes
pareilles méthodes vous parlez de
servier quoi bien entendu ne peut être
considéré comme un acteur de santé
publique responsable elle c'est à dire
que hormis servier tous les autres
laboratoires sur des acteurs de santé
publique responsable
sas a heurté si vous voulez ma pratique
qu'enfin moment je dirais momo
l'expérience que je pouvais avoir des
pratiques
des laboratoires en général qui sont des
pratiques tout à fait respectable dans
la mesure où elles ont pour objet de
vendre des médicaments et le plus de
médicaments possible on peut pas
demander de la part d'un laboratoire qui
a l'oeil rivé sur la bourse
on peut pas lui demander effectivement
d'avoir d'autres comportements en tout
cas c'est mon point de vue mais en ce
qui vous concerne vous semblez attendre
de ces firmes un comportement public de
santé publique responsable alors je
voulais savoir si c'est vous qui aviez
raison ou cissé ou cissé - qui avait
réseau lequel de nous deux avaient tort
alors par définition vous ne pouvez pas
avoir tort ce que je voulais dire
c'était deux choses la première en
particulier effectivement cette
interview réalisée après ses yeux le 16
janvier à maintenant on se tape avoir lu
tu peux être rapidement mais avait
attentivement l'ensemble du rapport de
l'igas et donc permettant d'avoir une
appréciation assez étayé sur le fait que
par rapport à ce qu'on voit en général
la stratégie que j'ai appelé d'enfumage
que l'on peut trouver tous les
qualificatifs était quand même
particulièrement marquée
particulièrement sophistiqué
particulièrement perverse et
malheureusement particulièrement
efficace deuxième chose que je pensais
c'est que par ailleurs je pense qu'il ya
besoin
d'inventer des médicaments peut-être pas
trop d'ailleurs
donc cela il ya un élément sur lequel je
reviendrai qui a besoin d'inventer des
médicaments il ya main mais je pense
qu'on a fait jouer aux laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
un rôle qui va au delà de celui qui doit
être le leur je pense pas donc je pense
que par exemple quand on nie
l'information sur le médicament
je ne pense pas que ce soit le rôle
direct de l'industrie pharmaceutique
premièrement deuxièmement son
intégration dans la chaîne de
pharmacovigilance qui hélas est
effectivement une action santé publique
je pense qu'on s'est trompé
troisièmement son intervention dans le
rôle de deux pilotes et deux financeurs
d'études qui peuvent avoir un impact la
santé publique là aussi on va trop loin
donc je pense effectivement dans
l'ensemble de la santé du secteur de la
santé l'industrie pharmaceutique est un
acteur qui doit être respecté et
respectable mais qu'effectivement il ne
faut pas lui confier un rôle qui le met
institutionnellement lui du coup en
conflit d'intérêts oui d'accord on est
d'accord sur ce point madame la java
vous posez des questions sur les
conflits d'intérêts les visiteurs
médicaux vous y avez répondu ma visite
médicale quand même il sera a été à sens
parce que vous permettez vous préconisez
la suppression de la visite médicale
mais est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
véritablement possible
est-ce qu'on peut interdire la moratoire
de déléguer un dé certains de ses
représentants pour aller voir certains
médecins libéraux qui sont consentants 1
pour leur expliquer que tel ou tel
produit est certainement ce qui a nui à
l'heure actuelle puisqu'il s'agit plus
d'information on est bien d'accord a dès
lors que c'est une entreprise qui fait
de l'information
ça n'est plus de l'information c'est de
la publicité
et c'est de la promotion donc il faut il
faut appeler les choses telles qu'elles
sont mais est ce que on a les moyens est
ce qu'on a le pour une société comme la
nôtre d'interdire aux médecins libéraux
de rencontrer des représentants des
firmes pharmaceutiques
c'est la question que je me pose pas ce
que ça fait partie d'une de vos
propositions la suppression de la visite
médicale alors quand on quand on met
cette proposition sur la table en
général la première chose vous réponds
c'est en réalité c'est pas du tout fait
pour influencer les médecins
la deuxième chose qu on vous répond en
général c'est que il ya un code de
déontologie parfait un sharp ou lire la
charte
oui c'est ce qu'affirme de vis fiscal
prévu oui alors lâché j'ai reçu une
lettre d'amour d'admonestation du
directeur général du lem pour
m'expliquer que en ayant parlé de la
visite médicale j'avais porté une grave
offense puisqu'il y avait un code de
déontologie qui faisaient que tout était
parfait je vais discuter avec des
médecins qui achève la has elle même
mais a conclu que la charte n'avait rien
changé et qu'elle n'était pas respecté
donc un résultat là dessus il ya des
textes donc on peut pas se prévaloir de
la charte
aujourd'hui pour valoriser la visite
médicale
à mon avis non et troisièmement on vous
répond en général que c'est
indispensable que c'est utile aux
médecins mais si je me trompe pas il ya
quand même 30 ou 40 médecins des
médecins libéraux qui ne reçoivent pas
les visiteurs médicaux il y en a qui se
portent pas dont les passions ne se
porte pas plus mal
il faut surtout demandé les aux patients
ce oui oui les patientes sous on n'a pas
d'information à tubes enfin non mais je
vois que c'est une étude qui serait
extrêmement intéressant à faire de
regarder
quel est le profil de prescriptions des
médecins qui reçoivent les visiteurs
médicaux et des médecins qui ne
reçoivent pas c'est je pense que ça
serait extraordinairement oui
instructif et illustratif
et oui alors oui on peut déjà je crois
sans risque de se tromper dire que ce
qu'ils reçoivent pas de visiteurs
uniques aux prescrits beaucoup moins que
ceux qui en reçoivent
je pense il en existe comment sais tu
dis que j'ai d'exister
je la connais pas je alors est-ce que
juridiquement on peut
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire la première
chose il faut pas oublier ta visite
médicale et payées par les cotisations
d'assurance maladie que nous payons et
par là csg sur donc on peut déjà
rendre
insupportable financièrement les je ne
sais pas si c'est entre 3 et 10
milliards d'euros que coûte la visite
médicale rapporte de l'ayguade oui vous
savez qu'il existe déjà une taxe qui a
justement pour effet de freiner les
dépenses de promotion
or depuis cette taxe les i salariés
empêchés 1 elle est totalement
inefficace
bon alors dont c'était pour essayer de
2,2 de pointer du doigt les les
difficultés en eau qu'on peut pour
obtenir un résultat avec une taxe la
deuxième chose me semble-t-il c'est que
si je crois pas qu'on puisse interdire
quelque chose de médecin je pense qu'on
peut tout à fait juridiquement le
législateur peut interdire à l'industrie
d'avoir cette action-là le les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques sur tout à
fait réglementée il ya des choses qu'ils
ont droit de faire des choses qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit de faire on a bien
interdit le démarchage on a bien
interdit il ya des tas de le colportage
ya des tas de choses de réglementation
qui existe un habit interdit la
propharmacie on peut pas donc je pense
qu'il n'y a aucun obstacle juridique
ensuite pu avoir une question
d'opportunité
il n'y a aucun obstacle juridique à dire
qu'un laboratoire pharmaceutique n'a pas
le droit d'aller faire la promotion
directe au cabinet médical autrement que
de pouvoir éventuellement présenter ces
médicaments dans telle ou telle enceinte
dans telle ou telle action à telle ou
telle occasion qui peut être tout à fait
cadres et je crois qu'il ya aucun
obstacle ni de valeur constitutionnelle
européenne ni que ça viole la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
bien sûr je n'ai la parole à monsieur
domaine qui veut vous poser une question
je lui donne volontiers la parole merci
monsieur le président un prédécesseur
dans le cadre des auditions de ce matin
l'ancien directeur général de la santé
leur dogme nous disait en gros il n'y a
pas de politique du médicament en france
alors est ce que vous partagez cette
assertion première chose et si oui
quelle serait pour une politique du
médicament en france
ça s'appelle section question la
deuxième la sécher un article sous les
yeux qui est libellé par jacques testart
que vous connaissez que directeur
honoraire de recherche à l'inserm et qui
dit qu' expertisera et scientifique
et il met en tête de son article se met
d'arbitrer les débats des débats de plus
en plus technique le monde politique se
tourner vers des experts afin d'éclairer
sa décision mais ceci pour être
compétents dans leur domaine sont trop
souvent liés aux intérêts du secteur
une expertise publique pourrait aider à
lever les sanctions et il pose la
question mais dans quelles conditions
première question sur la politique du
médicament est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut recentraliser avoir une direction
générale du médicament et où des
produits de santé au ministère qui
inclut non seulement le médicament mais
l'ensemble des produits de santé
les dispositifs médicaux et tout ce qui
est issu aussi de l' agence de
biomédecine dont un jour ou l'autre on
peut se demander si on va pas avoir un
peu alors moi je ne sais pas donner des
phrases définitives du genre il n'y a
pas de politique du médicament
il ya bien des politiques du médicament
est ce qu'elles sont bonnes mauvaises ou
et état mais il ya il ya une politique
du médicament
deuxièmement il ya effectivement
peut-être plus une politique des
médicaments qu'une politique du
médicament et je pense que s'il y avait
quelque chose à revoir
quand on réfléchit finalement on donne
un l'autorisation de le fonctionnement
de l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
par du précepte que si le rapport
bénéfices risques est favorable le
médicament peut être autorisée mais
après tout on n'a pas le raisonnement
inverse en disant il peut y avoir des
médicaments qu'un bon rap quand un
rapport bénéfice risque favorable mais
qui sont peut-être pas utile dans la
stratégie thérapeutique que doit
déployer un pays voyez ce que le cas je
reprends sur sur le médiator et tous ces
médicaments là en vous écoutant
interrogé mon prédécesseur à cette place
pour savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'avait pas entendu parler avant le
semis je pense tout simplement parce que
ces médicaments étaient traités par le
mépris médiator veinotoniques toute une
série de médicaments comme cela les
experts les profs de médecine considéré
ça pour eux ils n'avaient pas s'en
occuper plus que des pastilles valda et
et
et des bonbons etc voilà ça faisait
plaisir aux gens de pouvoir faire cela
il y avait une sorte de tolérance et de
de connivence sur le fait qu'on l'ait
laissé un peu remboursés parce que non
pas l'industrie pharmaceutique considéré
que toute une série de médicaments
doivent être un tout petit peu
remboursés
juste pour donner confiance aux patients
voilà et parce que il y avait dans la
stratégie l'idée un médicament remboursé
par la sécu est un médicament qui va me
guérir et donc le labo qu'il fait est à
la bourre respectable donc il ya eu
pendant longtemps effectivement une
réticence non pas les labos étaient
d'accord pour dire écoutez on met un
prix on le rembourse faiblement mais il
faut que le médecin puisse dire je vous
rends je vous prescrit un médicament
remboursé par la sécu donc avait toute
une danse qui clochait dans l'âme et
politique du médicament
il ya ceux là me semble-t-il
mais je reviens donc sur l'autorisation
de mise sur le marché moi il me semble
qui ressort de ce qu'on analyse
aujourd'hui a posteriori ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'il ne suffit pas de faire
d'évaluation effectivement au cas par
cas produit par produit pour donner le
feu vert
en imaginant qu'on va se rattraper
ensuite dans l'admission au
remboursement monde si ce n'est pas plus
en amont qui font considérer qu'il ya
médicaments qui peuvent avoir un rapport
bénéfice risque non défavorable mais
pour autant n'ont pas à être dans
l'arsenal thérapeutique mis mis sur le
marché
donc il ya parce que je suis claire là
dessus mais il me semble que quand on
fait le tour de l'ensemble des
spécialités
il ya en fait quand on raisonne à la
fois en matière sanitaire en matière
économique incertain de deux médicaments
qui n'ont peut-être pas leur place est
en fait ne peut les arrêter oui et qu'on
s'entende bien parce que quand un
médicament à un rapport bénéfice risque
présumé favorable parce que c'est
toujours sur une présomption quand même
un médicament sur le marché puisque
évidemment on l'a testé que sur un
nombre limité 1 2 de patience qui n'a
rien à voir avec le nombre d'ipad la
cible qui sera effectivement celle du
médicament dans la vraie vie
d'autant plus que ils le il sera
prescrit à des personnes âgées ou des
enfants qui n'auront pas forcément était
inclus dans les essais prêt à mêmes donc
à partir du moment où le rapport
bénéfices risques est favorable mais
dans la mesure où effectivement ce
rapport bénéfice/risque résultats
d'essais comparatifs par du moment où on
a bien démontré que ce médicament ou une
constituait un progrès thérapeutique par
rapport à ceux de la même famille qui
existe déjà sur le marché à partir de ce
moment là me semble-t-il
il n'y a aucune raison non seulement de
ne pas le mettre sur le marché mais
ensuite d'envisager son retrait sauf si
dans l'intervalle effectivement il ya
des alertes qui surviennent et qui
témoigne effectivement que lors de la
mise sur le marché
on a été trop optimiste on s'est trompé
la présomption était et des fois au sart
et c'est pour ça que cette distinction
vous importez pour moi je dirais qu'elle
est pas clair et peut-être que elle est
pertinente à mais j'attends de vous que
vous me le biais je pense qu'à partir du
moment où on a limité le nombre de
médicaments amm être mis sur le marché
en raison de cette précaution des ces
comparatifs c'est vrai que chaque année
il y aurait beaucoup moins de
médicaments mis sur le marché
actuellement si j'en juge les résultats
que j'observe chaque année qui sont ceux
de la commission de la transparence en
vertu du classement smr
il ya tout au plus 10 va médicaments
peut-être 30,1 chez à cadets sur les 300
nouveaux qu'on met sur le marché qui
devrait effectivement y être donc vous
voyez il ya là effectivement la
situation ne se pose plus du tout dans
les mêmes termes
là c'est le plus une observation qu'une
question parce que je vais tout à fait
dans l'autre sens avec ce paradoxe chuté
à des médicaments quoi dans le fait que
c'est l'industrie qu'elle a l'initiative
on a ce paradoxe il ya des médicaments
qui manquent par exemple les formules
pédiatrique pour un certain nombre de
médicaments et cal inverse ci a
effectivement mais peut-être gériatrique
etc l inverse il ya effectivement des
ddd innovations qui sont introduits qui
est qu'ils sont pas forcément d'une dune
d'une grande pertinence pour poursuit
donc pour poursuivre sur le sur les
questions que vous avez posé aussi sur
faut-il recentrer c'est à dire 10 ou de
dissoudre les agences en tant
qu'établissement public pour un mois mon
point de vue est très ferme c'est non
parce qu'il faut pas se leurrer il faut
le mythe selon lequel à ont retransmis
ray du directeur général de l'afssaps au
ministre est un leurre absolu on
transférerait pas au ministre quoi il ya
regarder le ministre de vous imaginer le
ministre de la santé du travail et de
l'emploi compte ni des attributions
qu'il l'a regardé
signé les a et même ça n'est pas
possible donc il leur déléguerait dont
qu'il déléguerait à une à une à une
administration qui donc on se
retrouverait dans la dilution des
migrations et là il n'y aurait plus de
responsables parce que le il vaut mieux
avoir un directeur général responsable
qu'un ministre facialement responsable
donc je pense que c'est vraiment une
fausse bonne idée et que ce serait même
un un danger majeur un danger majeur
parce que en fait le système qui a
défailli est un système qu'on peut faire
marcher un système dans lequel les
ministères et les administrations
au niveau national comme au niveau
européen sont chargés des
réglementations général et et des
orientations et où les opérateurs
publics le faisant avec un certain
nombre de règles et de cadres sont dans
l'application d'un cadre général dont
ils ne sont pas à l'origine pour prendre
les décisions et organiser les
expertises et la deuxième chose je ne
pense pas que la fameuse chose que j'ai
entendue 36 fois sur la séparation de la
décision de la gestion et l'évaluation
que j'entendais quand je m'occupais de
sécurité alimentaire soit une
distinction pertinente
c'est à dire que autant il faut séparer
la gestion économique d'un problème de
la gestion sanitaire d'un problème il
faut pas que ce soit la même autorité
qui est la responsabilité entre les deux
mais prenez garde si les recommandations
vont dans le sens d'avoir il ya d'un
côté une organisation d' expertise et il
ya de l'autre côté celui qui prend les
décisions d'avoir finalement un système
dans lequel il ya une qu ils
responsabilité moi j'ai vu ça dans le
domaine de la sécurité alimentaire
parce que j'ai dirigé une agence qui
n'avaient pas les pouvoirs de police de
gestion et on m'expliquait que lorsque
donc on était censé notre mission fixée
par le législateur proposition de loi
sénatoriale excellente
à cette nuance près donc notre
responsabilité est de pouvoir
à garantir et assurer la sécurité
sanitaire quand nous avions un avis
d'expert mais que nous pressentions que
dans les abattoirs dans les arrière
cuisines etc
il y avait des règles et des préceptes
qui n'étaient pas respectées et donc que
les bonnes recommandations scientifiques
n'avaient aucun sens par rapport à la
réalité on m'expliquait que ça ne me
regardait pas parce que c'était la
gestion du risque c'était de la sphère
de la gestion du risque et donc on se
paraient l'un et l'autre et donc ont peu
à voir si vous rompez la chaîne
c'est difficile de dire ça parce que le
système n'a pas marché pour le médiator
c'est pour ça que je ne pense qu'on peut
l'interpréter par un système qui a été
un moment sous influence mais si vous
rompez cette chaîne là vous risquez de
recréer des renvois de balle et d
irresponsabilité
je pense que les préceptes poste
transfusion sanguine consistant à dire
on sépare les responsabilités
économiques des responsabilités
sanitaires points deuxièmement que du
côté des responsabilités sanitaires
on identifie des responsables avec la
responsabilité de l'autorisation et du
retrait des produits ne doit pas être
jeté à la poubelle qui doivent être
rénovés qu'ils doivent être à mon sens
confortés qu'ils doivent être mieux
identifier qu'il doit avoir sa propre
liberté jeu je pense que ce qui a été
curieux ces dernières années c'est qui a
finalement eu pas de crise sanitaire et
il faut se méfier quand j'exerçais des
responsabilités dans ce domaine qui
avait des crises on s'engueulait avec
des ministres il y avait des problèmes
sur tel ou tel produit alimentaire
c'était sympa ce que le système si le
système d'or ça veut dire qu'il ya des
drames qui se prépare un donc je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient contre 97 en a
supprimé pondérale et isoméride et
médiator
absolument oui mais le répète c'est la
mla le moment où ça va dans deux tiroirs
étanche est un moment qui reste
mystérieux même quand on lit l'ensemble
du rapport de l'igas oui oui alors
j'avoue que j'ai pas très bien compris
hein vous vous voulez donc
revisité en tout cas cette ce principe
qui me semble est fondamental de la
séparation de l'évaluation du risque de
la gestion du risque
je croyais que et alors on les
explications que vous avez donné ma
paresse convaincante mais ça se
traduirait sur le plan je dirais
organisationnelles des institutions par
quoi est ce qu'il faut maintenir les
institutions qui existent actuellement
les agences en place ce qu'il faut
donner des compétences un peu plus
étendus au directeur général de
l'afssaps par exemple ou au contraire
al'inverse donner des compétences plus
étendue aux ministres puisque
actuellement le directeur général de
l'afssaps prend des décisions concernant
médicaments au nom du ministre et le
ministre il n'y a pas de droit d'appel
par exemple le ministre peut pas en
appeler aux directeurs pour lire
attention vous avez pris une décision
nous allons tel médicament
je suis pas d'accord revoyez votre votre
dossier et c'est donc comment je
comprends bien que la gestion économique
et que la gestion sanitaire doit être
séparé ce qui est le cas d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui au moins formellement un
même si sur le plan dans la réalité ça
n'est pas aussi simple que ça mais sur
le plan de 2 du du risque
l'évaluation de nationalisation du riste
la séparation est quand même n'être donc
est ce que après ce que vous n'êtes dire
il faut modifier un ces institutions ou
les rapports que le ministre entretient
avec elle ou est-ce que les lignes de
démarcation au lieu d'être entre
évaluation et gestion du rib notre
expertise et décision au risque d'aller
un peu à contre-courant de ce qui se dit
je ne pense pas que y est à bousculer le
système institutionnel et
organisationnel
vraiment pas premièrement deuxièmement
je pense assez logique que le ministre
n'ait pas à faire appel parce que quoi
ne puisse pas revenir sur une décision
sinon ça déresponsabilise à la limite on
pourrait imaginer qu'ils puissent avoir
un pouvoir conservatoire de pousser à la
suspension ou le retrait s'ils
considèrent que l'autorité sanitaire
n'est pas assez forte mais pas dans
l'autre sens quand on a évoqué en 94-95
un pouvoir d'appel ce qui a été évoqué
c'était pas dans l'idée d'être plus
forts en matière de sécurité sanitaire
c'était plus que l'industrie qui avait
peur que le gendarme le sanctionne trop
et c'est pour ça qu'on voulait laisser
cette marge de manoeuvre donc qui est un
clapet dans un sens peut-être face à une
autorité sanitaire pour lequel le
ministre aurait un faisceau d'indicés
pour dit attendez je préfère qu'on se
pose complètement
je pense que ce qu'il faut revoir
juridiquement c'est les conditions de
retrait là aussi c'est ça ce qui est
absolument extravagant quand on lit les
choses c'est de voir que il ya que les
autorités sanitaires ont tant apporté de
preuves pour pouvoir sécuriser leur
décision de suspension ou de retrait et
ça devrait fonctionner dans l'autre sens
c'est ça moi aussi ça m'a frappée je
n'avais pas conscience de cela
donc il faut que les procédures de
retrait de suspension soit beaucoup plus
sécurisé pour qu'on ne tremble pas de
voir sa décision annuler une
condamnation
aux intervenants cision administrative
non mais on ne peut pas empêcher que
celui qui se sent lésé puisse engager
une action contre cette décision
bien bien bien sûr que non mais non en
matière de prévention on peut aussi
empêcher cas si on veut faire de la
prévention
ça veut dire que on ne peut pas je pense
qu'on peut dire que sauf erreur
manifeste d'appréciation il ya les
juristes à faire cela on peut considérer
que d'avoir appliqué le principe de
précaution c'est à dire suspendu usage
de médicaments pendant deux ans pour
finalement éventuellement lever les
préventions
on doit va pas faire payer à l'autorité
sanitaire le fait d'avoir protégé les
patients quand il le semble et donc non
et moi je suis d'accord avec vous mais
le conseil d'état ne l'est pas forcément
il appelait l'histoire du clae du
kétoprofène est là pour prouver que
quelquefois une action alors là qui
était tout à fait appel à l'honneur de
l'afssaps a été agacé par la la le
conseil d'état il est vrai que cette
décision de l'afssaps était en
contradiction avec celle de l'europe est
assurée il n'empêche que on peut pas
dans le même temps celui reproché à
l'afssaps de ne pas suspendre ourdan est
assez et puis s'apercevoir que le
conseil d'état n'a pas du tout n'est pas
du tout dans les mêmes dispositions quoi
puisque comme vous êtes je crois savoir
aussi conseiller d'état laisse moi je
pense que vous êtes mieux que quiconque
en mesure de répondre à papa mieux que
quiconque mais mieux mieux enfin doivent
pas mieux mais autant autant par nos en
tout cas bien placé bien car ce que au
dessus de la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état il ya la loi et à la loi donc il
faudrait alors je pense qu'il faut à la
fois que la loi et les textes européens
prévoient que
les conditions dans lequel on puisse
suspendre en tout cas suspendre une
autorisation de mise sur le marché soit
plus simple plus rapide doivent être
moins argumentée qu' on ne l'exigent
aujourd'hui donc il faudrait un modifier
les textes législatifs que dont nous
disposons dans notre pays bien entendu
et au niveau européen qu'ils nous
restent effectivement je pense que là le
niveau européen l'emportent sur la loi
française
oui alors ça c'est une autre paire de
manches 1 mais je pense que on
découvrirait je pense que ce qui s'est
passé en france il ya c'est assez
logique à une focalisation sur le
mediator parce qu'on pensait en france
être finalement à avoir remédier à ces
problèmes là je pense que tous les pays
européens peuvent être confrontés au
même problème que celui qu'on a
rencontrés et a dramatiquement sur le
médiator en france tels que bien avez
vous d'autres questions oui madame blood
nous entendons des avis très contrastés
sur séparation non séparation de
l'expertisé de la décision moi je
m'intéresse plus à la déontologie et la
fiabilité de l' expertise elle même
qu'elle soit proche ou pas de la
décision et
dans cet article on évoque cette haute
autorité de l'expertisé de l'e lerte une
espèce d'inspection permanente sur
conflits d'intérêts respect des
protocoles confrontation avec des études
étrangères et surtout écoute des
lanceurs d'alert pour en faire fruits
pour obliger éventuellement une
recherche complémentaire mais ne pas
rater des alertes comme celle d'irène
frachon
or ce qui n'est pas dit dans l'article
c'est qu'on l'a voté à l'unanimité dans
une loi grenelle promulguée en 2009 en
juillet 2009 et que rien en est sorti de
ce vote alors que c'était l'unanimité
des deux chambres et a posteriori on se
dit bah alors on l'a la solution et c
est ma question c'est est-ce que votre
vécu intérieur des cabinets ou votre
observation de l'extérieur peut nous
faire soupçonner que les firmes sont
suffisamment puissante pour influencer
des ministres sur la mise en oeuvre ou
non d'un morceau d'une loi parce que moi
c'était un amendement que j'ai portée et
je peux vous dire que j'en suis très
marie singes nouveau mais vraiment ça me
tournante quoi c'est la légitimité du
parlement qui est bafouée la réponse est
oui oui bien sûr la réponse est oui
la réponse est clairement oui mais ce
que je pense c'est que moi tout mon
propos consiste à essayer de montrer que
même les meilleurs codes de déontologie
toi tu ne résisteront jamais si les
médecins les chercheurs les experts ne
peuvent pas faire leur boulot sans avoir
besoin quand vous mettez vous prenez
quelqu'un qui voudrait sauver le monde
en inventant des médicaments qui fait
ses études de médecine fait un doctorat
de biologie pas ce concours pour être
chargé de recherche à l'inserm ou au
cnrs il a envie de trouver des
médicaments
on lui donne pas de sou public un
laboratoire pharmaceutique vient le voir
en disant écoutez on va vous envoyer au
congrès de san francisco où il ya les
meilleurs du monde premièrement
deuxièmement vous avez besoin de sous
pour faire fonctionner votre truc au
vote vous aurez cela on n'arrive pas à
vous mettre un assistant de recherche
on vous le paye et c'est par passion et
c'est normal il ne peut pas dire non
voilà et comme c'est un bon gars parce
qu'il veut sauver le monde
quand il se trouve dans la commission ou
tel produit sur la sellette
c'est pas un pervers donc ça l'embêté
raïs dit oh là là si je dis ce
médicament il faut le retirer et dit
c'est quand même pas sympa pour celui
qui m'a permis par ailleurs de financer
mes recherches qui vont peut-être me
permettre de sauver les petits enfants
c'est ça le vice elle a donc ensuite
vous mettez la meilleure commission de
déontologie de comitologie d'expertisé
etc
il ne se passera rien donc vraiment je
reprends s'il n'y a pas un financement
public car quand on regarde toutes les
directives qui ont été données mais j'ai
vécu l'intérieur moi j'ai je voyais ça
sur la sécurité alimentaire sur la
sécurité alimentaire me suis permis
l'autre jour 2 de relever cela il ya la
gent ce que j'ai dirigé auparavant
assortie ya quelques mois un rapport sur
les régimes amaigrissants disons la
méthode machin la méthode bidule c'est
pas bien ne disons pas un mot de ce que
les pilules c'est bizarre c'est juste
avant médiator que les pilules
amaigrissantes ouattara pouvait avoir un
impact bon j'ai regardé le président de
ce comité d'experts
il a effectivement sa déclaration
d'intérêts
il est payé par les quatre principaux
rôles par quatre gros laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
il a des liens internet quatre gros
laboratoires pharmaceutiques c'est
compliqué d'avoir de monter des
recherches avec les labos même si les
essais salah le poison du conflit
d'intérêts c'est que c'est pas des gens
malhonnêtes
c'est des gens dans la vie il plus durs
dans la vie c'est dire non à une belle
femme ou un beau sujet ou et cetera
voilà donc je pense que la la il peut
pas y avoir de bonnes déontologie s'il
n'ya pas en face un bon dénouement des
conflits d'intérêts institutionnels des
organismes de recherche face à
l'industrie pharmaceutique
il faut remonter loin là dedans on a
trop intriqués l'un et l'autre et il n'y
a plus de contrepoids à l'innovation à
il ya plus de contrepoids public pour
pouvoir et on s'arrache les cheveux pour
trouver effectivement des experts qui
sur la protection des lanceurs d alerte
bien évidemment moi je me souviens de
pierre meneton je sais pas s'il vous
souvenez de pierre mouton pour le seul
vers mento on a essayé de le
déstabiliser
on a essayé de le déstabiliser par les
services secrets pour dire qu'en fait il
était payé par la cia pour déstabiliser
l'industrie pharmaceutique française
c'était quand même c'était quand même
assez spectaculaire voilà je revendique
de l'avoir défendu nous avons organisé
du coup il était venu me voir
un colloque financer uniquement sur
fonds publics pour mettre absolument
tout à fait
bien alors une autre question peut être
une des dernières puisque le temps que
le temps s'écoule un bon vous vous
préconisez effectivement le retrait et
je suis d'accord avec vous delà de
l'industrie pharmaceutique de tous les
secteurs de la santé qu'elle a investi
en raison du retrait du service peut
enfin deux des pouvoirs publics que pour
des raisons uniquement financières donc
qu'est-ce que quelles mesures préconisez
vous pour pour le financement
effectivement pour pour permettre le
financement de ses activités qui jusque
là étaient financées par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
et puis j'aurai ensuite une deuxième
question sur la recherche mais bon allez
si si on regarde combien ça coûte
aujourd'hui aux finances publiques
ce système là on peut prendre le surcoût
de la consommation de médicaments en
france par rapport à d'autres pays va
faire quelques milliards on peut prendre
le coût direct des dépenses de promotion
et c'est encore à voir voir donc on va
voir
il ya un peu un peu immature milliards
oui voilà donc à mon avis ça doit pas
être extrêmement compliqué déjà
directement en se privant de certains
types de dépenses de pouvoir récupérer
un peu d'argent quelques centaines de
millions d'euros pour financer plutôt
des laboratoires de recherche dans
lequel qui travaillerait sur les risques
qu'ils travailleraient sur évasion qui
pourrait donc reproduire de l' expertise
publique indépendante des intérêts
économiques
je pense qu'avec ça on devrait pouvoir
financer la formation médicale continue
des médecins et que dans un deuxième
temps cet effet là et les directives
qu'il pourrait donner en matière d'une
politique de médicaments effectivement
moins à guichet ouvert devrait permettre
là aussi de faire quelques économies et
on doit pouvoir se fixer l'objectif
plutôt que d'augmenter les
déremboursements
de diminuer la masse des médicaments
remboursés tout ça nécessite quelques
années ah oui pour vous il s'agit pas
par exemple de envisager une baisse et
des médicaments du prix des médicaments
de façon à faire réaliser les économies
à l'assurance maladie qui en
contrepartie pourrait financer
directement ou indirectement ses
activités qui serait qu'ils seraient
plus financées par les juges dans la
première doit dans un premier temps si
on disait quand j'ai ensuite après la
vie est beaucoup plus compliqué que ce
que je dis mais si on fait le
raisonnement si on disait ce que les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques dépenses en
uruguay 1 promotion et son café glacé en
etc ils ne dépensent plus qu'ils payent
aujourd'hui c'est la sécurité sociale
donc on peut leur soit leur baisser les
prix soient les taxer de la somme
équivalente naco premier première argent
qui doit pouvoir être reconcentrer cette
fois sous contrôle public de ddd des
fonctions qui ne sont plus assurés
deuxième étape si on ne se trompe pas
dans notre raisonnement
ceci devrait alléger la pression
économique qu il y assure le
prescripteur la pression économique
qu'il ya sur le sur le patient la
pression économique qui assure un
certain nombre d'acteurs et du coup
avoir une influence sur la console
consommation de médicaments dans ce très
vertueux et donc dans un deuxième temps
on doit encore contribuer à baisser le
déficit de l'assurance maladie
les choses sont toujours beaucoup plus
compliqué qu'on ne le dit mais quand
même je pense qu'on est dans un schéma
qui est exactement à l'opposé de cela
donc rien ne désespère de penser qu'il
peut être mis en oe faut pas même si on
peut effectivement avoir quelques doutes
sur de voir un jour prochain
appliquer des mesures aussi radicales
il n'empêche pas qu'on peut les proposer
comme l'expérience montre que jamais un
gouvernement ne reprend ou très rarement
les propositions d'un rapport sénatorial
et c'est mais ça a peut-être changé
ça a peut-être changé ça a peut-être
changé oui je rappelais que l' agence du
médicament et est issue d'un rapport
sénatorial oui l'afssaps il oui issus du
position loi sénatoriale l' agence du
service civique que je préside
issue d'une proposition ua sénatoriales
et le rsa trouve parmi ces paternité le
rapport de valérie létard oui on est
dans le domaine du médicament
oui moi je fais je ne fais mon mea lui
oui oui le club du sénat oui vous vous
reconnaissez que dans le domaine du
médicament on a on a plus de difficile
on a plus de difficultés
on a plus de difficulté bien alors
écoutez je pense que sous réserve qu'il
n'y ait plus de deux questions je vous
remercie infiniment pour cette
contribution dont nous allons faire
notre miel comme vous vous faites le
miel des amendements sénatoriaux heureux
merci encore